I mean this is where i would say that
religious faith in its broader sense
always does of a role to play in society
because if you I mean you say well
China's not become religious over the
decades which in one sentence is true
but in another sense the philosophical
underpinnings of Chinese society very
much located in Confucius which of
course is a very moral I mean philosophy
even if you say it's not a religion okay
and actually likewise with the Japanese
in fact if you think of the Shinto
philosophy and I actually think
sometimes the only way that that you
persuade people to reconciliation is
where you're able to persuade them that
the act of reconciliation is actually
consistent with their basic
philosophical belief system you know
what i mean so it might not necessarily
be consistent with the religious
philosophical system but nonetheless you
persuade them there is nothing alien
without the philosophical values that
underpin our society for this act of
forgiveness to happen see what i mean so
and you see i think that actually no
society i mean this is why you know
communism in its most extreme form as
practice in the cultural revolution as
practiced in cambodia's practiced in
today North Korea never never succeeds
it doesn't succeed because it attempts
to eliminate these philosophical values
which are drawn on a very human what i
would call also very spiritual even if
not religious in the strict sense of the
word spiritual experience that's
developed over time and so i think we're
one of the interesting things is that
religion and i gave the example of
sierra
but where religious groups can play a
part in a reconciliation even if the
conflict is not itself religious in
nature and if you extend that from the
religious to the philosophical then I
think in that this Chinese case it does
in fact I you know my theory of this
Roman actually is that as a conversation
I have with the Chinese leadership and I
Satan unless people understand what
makes Chinese people tick in terms of
you know what is it that they how do
they feel spiritually about the world
they're going to be frightened of you
you know that's what I say they're going
to be scared of you you know is that if
I can't locate someone not just as a
transactional relationship but in some
sense something deeper and broader and I
would say more spiritual Matt then I
just I I would find that I would find
myself recoiling from that a little not
not not knowing how to treat it and deal
with it so actually I think this is a
very very important question in the
development of not just Chinese society
but also China's relations with the art
with the outside world and I think that
as with all religion in my view answers
are called deep within people in this
concept of forgiveness i think is very
very deep within people it's something
that you know is there is something in
the human spirit that has this concept
with within it so I don't know will be
interesting to see ya